where'd you grow up where you from
originally I was born in Lynwood
California st. Francis Hospital but I
grew up in first Chicago Illinois then I
moved to Georgia with Savannah Richmond
County all in Springfield Chicago have
noise is 1821 south Springfield I stayed
on the street Springfield what's up in
middle school yeah and then after that I
moved to Atlanta Georgia no I did but I
didn't know him but you know ended up in
a foster home at 8 months old but the
lady I grew up for us so I was 17 years
old but my mom let's crack here my dad I
never did no one but when I did fight
night he was a real good man yes I was a
very high smoker and I smoked now but I
really start smoking because that's the
reason why I smoked is because my mom
wouldn't deal with me unless I smoked
crack and that's the only communication
yeah worst times my life is going up at
five years old it was real bad um
knowing from finding out that I had a
brother that I don't know about was I'd
sleep my bed every single night where I
get raped every night every night every
night by my brother which was the first
brother was I never known I thought was
a real brother fires OH I used to
remember everything I've never
everything south fires up and I mom you
see literally make me sleep by his bed
why he performs his duties every single
night and as I got older I tripped me
out but the more I was younger is the
worst because my mom she's like one of
the worst moms every book all my life
want to know who she was but when I got
older I didn't want to find out I want
to find out what she was but I didn't
want to find out she was due to the fact
what I went through which at age is
eight months old I was doctor
I remember I found out that I saw her
but she's telling me of my brothers in
them to Chuck drivers it was six boys
six girls this is my older sisters
I was like one of the ones she didn't
like so I was like torture she trusted
me regardless but when I turned like
five years old I should see my mom when
she used to take me and my buzzing them
to building words they called lot
lizards where the truck drivers go where
they sell prostitutes she says so she
used to tell my little brother's name go
to the truck and needs to go in and I
just stand there like and then one day I
did that and I was one of the ones in
the road I usually didn't be that but I
guess as time went on she had her
favorites I wasn't one of our favorites
so she sent me today and I used to be
able to talk to I was used to touch all
on me it's funded we've been funneling
in and playing it's a cry but I got used
to it I was like going that was wrong
about I was wrong about five years old
that's when I first met he started
knowing what six was five years old um
tell Stan just listen
yeah it took it was in a lot of like
Savannah like Richmond County right
somewhere up in there it was in the
south part where nobody could do it you
would never think you could ever know
stuff going like that so yeah for money
for drugs drugs drugs and to pay off
drug dealers that she hold 5007 then the
sentence while living and they said
sounds my brother why are you having a
baby with him when I turned 17 just
makes Levi's bed every night after the
check-kiting stuff that's when the
brother came in and every single night
she's making sleepy eyes bed so second
7:00 on down I was 11 there's 11 I was
13 and then one day I told her when I
turned like 15 16 I was like yeah your
son is up when you leave he's molesting
me but he used to call them templates
an army like yeah yeah can I speak to my
sister I said like no I don't talk to
her she still made me get on the phone
so I told her about eleven thirteen you
know yeah when I was like 13 I told her
that what happened she wouldn't believe
me I was like aah son she's like no what
did he do when she knew already you know
said she just wanted see if I remember
someone's at school but there's a little
bit he said she looked up whoo walked me
like beat me I went to school with a
belly shirt on it's a little bitty
shorts and I went to school and I sat
down in the classroom and the teacher is
like in this bad boy
okay I'm like I the same thing I seen
all the whips on my arm
she took me outside she asked me what's
going on and I said my mom with me came
back in the classroom i sat down I said
five minutes later the police came and
social services went to lady house each
other that she can have anymore
that's when I found out she was my real
mom on it but a long life thinks she's
my mom because I was so little
stop digging is my mom but it wasn't my
turn when I told her that in 16 she knew
she was doing but I didn't know but then
then she was like she know I'm doing mom
tomorrow and then I end up going to a
farm where my dad he died he always said
before I die I want you to know he'll
your sisters are he found him he died
and I find my sister I found I was
pregnant no this is the brother mmm ate
my song down to 16 years old so I told
her what her son was doing I didn't win
but my mom knew the lady though the
later is because the lady properly took
me from her my mom because they both was
like drug dealers like they both smoked
together but my mom know that she's the
ladies gonna switch I mean she liked me
so much that she took me from so I heard
my mom with the court for me and then
end up she she get me him I met my mom
and I turn 18 when I was 17 with my dad
died and she's still the same way well
now she got killed by the grass sleep
but see I killed by the grass slipper
the guy had the grand Reaper yeah never
my mom she stayed at home right there on
wall in Broadway like she's along at her
own spot I used to have my own spot too
and I stayed appearance and stuff but I
looked back and forth finish streets
because I really want snore but she
really didn't want to know me and say
unless I cracked she didn't want to see
me but I've been down here in two years
but six months I already get outside
it's just I've been out here
I got sodomized I got raped I'm gonna
keeping up with my eight month old son
wish to God says right here in the
corner I don't know if you know the big
girl
Keisha she have a brother named Jamie
well yeah him he gave me something's
called trap dope where I was doing
crystal for 20 years when I got with the
guy he was doing crystal and where they
put hair on inside the crystal and it's
called check dope so come find out I was
trapped in a house for like eight days
up me and my son eight months old
and the last day was they found out I
had a lawsuit where my son had died
before him the California hospital yeah
they found a lawsuit paper when I went
to the hospital for my seizure and so
what they started doing they start
giving me stuff to chat me there it's
where they could get enough time to go
through the paperwork fine I was going
on disguise herself as me and give me a
my son but me being a strong person that
I am I broke through that so I broke
through that has been the bottle came
out with crystal like you know you give
a baby sugar water it was crystal water
I'm big one wake up I was up for seven
days like wow I certainly wasn't moving
wasn't moving how I got away is um
they always up so long trying to kidnap
me and my son get the money they're not
falling asleep and lord have mercy I
called the ambulance
got there mama because there was there's
chest eyes on her - I'm kind of fun that
was all over some losses I have ten I
have five boys and five girls my oldest
is 19 he's doing 90 years for murder
my second son two of my kids there and
you talk because me and dad got until I
left when I was in 17 years
mmm 2016 I left them in Vegas I came
down here I mean they had no benefits I
gave him to his sons which is the same
name as him Demetrius and Demetrius
they went to Utah where he was dealing
with a girl out here that we used by
Christopher and they had moved to Utah
Dimitri and Demetrius this IOUs and I
see II
Antoine Antoine one is junior and one is
the third yeah and my oldest is my Tabas
they turn Bebek yeah and I have a Gary
on Charles Brewer and D'Angelo sake Juan
Brewer my daughter's five answer nation
and a station kawaii Stephanie in Paris
yeah so five boys five girls all right
six of my kids six before the dad I get
a dad too after 11 2016 so he can take
care of two of his boys and I want a
crystal meth head lady and they moved it
Texas out there the growing of stabbing
them they went he went to jail they put
my two boys that I gave him for benefits
in stayed in a hotel but they put him in
up what you call it a shelter well he
went to jail he got out when he got out
he came to the place crystal meth out
and they took the boys from him so now
my boys are divided into which I talk to
him every single day one of my King in
attachment but the other one I talk to
every day
that's the Dimitra centimeters and
there's some beasts they just like their
mom but they have no feelings because
all I did was get beat like my oldest
son baby that I was where he shot my
little something baby gun
it's one of the Dimitra says he hitmen
either Bell Buckle because he wouldn't
go to sleep and he's choked out by a
mono daughter which became Down syndrome
because she wouldn't stop crying and I
was working that label reading in Las
Vegas you know so you know saying I was
like I did what my kids so I was a
threat it's my kids because they feel
like I was put them in danger with
family members when I was really working
and doing I'm supposed to do but others
is on other type of chemical drugs to
where I can perform my duties as a mom
I'm saying I used to couldn't send her
to school with ragging shoes are on
people look at him
I spend 12 hours every single month
pregnant on the bicycle to pay rent for
him when I stayed in Bakersfield Georgia
like I did everything on my own until
now I'm still tied to everything alone
but it's just easy but life is very hard
because now I'm good this situation with
my daughter her name is definitely with
key Brewers she was kidnapped
March the 23rd and her birthday is March
24th she came out here to find me they
never found her they had a APB out
everybody know about it she knew where I
was but they never said in a fire she
still go right now no now it's a
situation where I'm going through well
now every night I hear the screams like
my mom helped me and it's driving me
crazy
because I've been hearing for the house
six months and it's not a not a game my
daughter she's 15 years old
she looks just like me yep and she's out
here somewhere and a lot of people know
that's they way of feeling that they got
me and I said but I won't let it out and
say you have to get evidence in order to
you know just you can't just walk there
and say oh yeah she's in the room she's
here she's here and then they get there
and then they think you're crazy
sinister person oh I have to be strong
for her but she says when she still
spent six months seven months and she's
out here somewhere close and everybody
knows it but you know saying I gotta be
strong that's what I'm trying to get my
place and started everything I supposed
to do exercise I'm going to sober living
on Monday
I'm saying it's fall for my kids and I'm
glad I could speak this because right
now I'm not too emotional because uh I
used the drug as a numbness and it's not
I didn't use any
so it's not making no emotions come as I
would when I didn't talk to last time
yes and I think up doing great no not
today I'm sober no pounds yes Daddy